i will speak now to our special
correspondent alex crawford uh joining
us now from kiev alex good to see you
this morning um i mean we've just been
reporting on that mod intelligence
briefing suggesting that the russians
are still stuck some 25 kilometers from
the center of the capital but is the
scene behind you reveals they don't have
to be there to destroy the place
they definitely don't and certainly near
the center we're about 10 kilometers
away from our center it feels very
secure people are definitely
beginning to come back out onto the
streets even shops and some restaurants
are opening uh they're planting flowers
they feel quite secure i think right in
the center but from even from where we
were we could hear the volley of
explosions late last night and if i just
step away and show you there's a massive
amount of devastation and of course not
only is this a gym a huge big shopping
center
it's also in the heart of an industrial
area and behind us and in front of this
blast there are
residential homes and flats many of them
have had their windows blown out and the
fronts um
shattered so and we know according to um
the police so far there are about four
confirmed deaths the the locals here in
the the people who are living all around
who are utterly terrified we've been
speaking to a few of them
this morning believe that the number of
casualties could be much higher and of
course it's not just the it's not just
the um the devastation it's causing it's
the absolute terrorist terrifying
moments that you're going through when a
volley of of rockets and missiles are
landing right next to you people talk
about it feeling like an earthquake and
they're absolutely terrified even if
they're not actually in caught up and
hurt themselves they're very scared so
vitalik the mayor of kiev is um
giving a very defiant message and saying
that they're never going to give in but
there's a lot of of terror once again on
the streets of kiev